as another hint i will take the same
matrix matrix a and take its determinant
again but i will do it using a different
technique and either technique is is
valid so here we're saying what's the
determinant of the three by three matrix
a and what we can do is we can rewrite
the first two columns so this column
right over here we can rewrite it as 4
negative 2 and then the second column
right over here
we can rewrite so it's negative 1
five
and zero and what we can do is we can
take the sum of the products of the
first three top left to bottom right
diagonals let me show you so the product
of
that
plus that
i'm trying my best to draw this neatly
and then from that subtract
the top right to bottom left diagonals
so from that subtract let me get a color
i haven't used
subtract
that
and that
so i know it's really confusing with all
these things i've drawn but let's look
at the blue ones first we have four
times 5 times 0
4 times 5 times 0
plus negative 1 times 3 times negative 2
plus negative 1 times 3 times negative
2.
let me put these in parentheses
plus 1 times 4 times 0
1 times 4 times 0 and then we're going
to subtract all of these orange
diagonals that go from the top right to
the bottom left so we're going to
subtract we could do 1 times 5 times
negative 2
1 times five times negative
two and then we could subtract subtract
four times three times zero four times
three times zero and then we can
subtract negative one times 4 times 0
negative 1 times 4 times 0. and now we
just evaluate this over here
4 times 5 times 0 is just 0.
negative 1 times 3 times negative 2 is
positive 6 so this is positive six
one times four times zero is zero once
again
and then we have
one times five times negative two is
negative ten but then we have this
negative out here so it becomes a
positive ten
then we have four times three times zero
well that's just going to be zero
and we have negative one times four
times zero which is just zero so we're
left with positive six plus ten
which is equal to
16.